so power is creating wearable kinetic
chargers which are devices that use
human motion like walking moving to
charge today's electronics so we take
the energy from walking and convert it
to useful electricity to charge portable
electronics like cellphones lights GPS
and other sensors I first knew I wanted
to be an entrepreneur when I did the
senior design project in the mechanical
engineering department before then I
didn't know what entrepreneurship was at
all just develop something that I kind
of fell in love with and the technology
you know I couldn't give it up I wanted
to see it working i wanted to see people
using it because i knew how much of an
impact it could have on people everybody
has an extracurricular activity that
they enjoy and that they're really
passionate about and many of those
things end up helping people later in
life so they sort of combine their
passion with their major and that is
exactly what is necessary to be a
successful entrepreneurs there's
something about CMU students that I
think you can't really find anywhere
else and no matter whether people go
into academia or they go into the
workforce or they start their own
company the thing that kind of connects
to all students on campus is passion for
something I ended up kind of taking my
engineering skills that I learned in
internships and at school and spinning
off a company which is something I never
thought I was going to do
you